[Music]
this was an opportunity for people of
all faiths and none to come together and
show solidarity with ukraine
voices from inside the war-torn country
echoed around winchester cathedral via a
series of video messages
people listened in silence as they spoke
of their place i think in a time of
crisis we need to come together and
reflect and try to channel our feelings
positively so that we don't drift into
despair because there are things that we
can do
the government has plans for a new
humanitarian scheme where uk families
can apply to take in refugees from
ukraine with no ties to britain for a
minimum of six months
i would if i had a spare room but i
haven't i've only got a little flat
yeah i hope so yeah and we need to do
something don't we obviously it's quite
difficult at the moment
especially like covered and stuff still
lingering about not sure how sure people
would be about it i don't see enough
kindness from the home secretary she
seems to be saying
we're doing everything we can to help
but there's a kind of brexit culture
behind it all the latest yougov poll
indicates almost one in five people
would offer accommodation to a ukrainian
family
pretty well everybody across
the united kingdom has sown incredible
support towards the ukrainian people
whether that's giving money whether it's
giving
things that they can provide or whether
it's providing sanctuary and like many
many other people i'd be more than happy
to play my part in that
on the ground in neighbouring moldova
one in eight children is now a refugee
from ukraine
when
those children are relocated to safe
spaces either within ukraine itself
or over borders it's done in a proper
and effective way so that we can trace
their families we can ensure they can go
back to their families in due course and
that we don't expose them in any way to
forms of trafficking or other forms of
exploitation
this was a poignant service with a very
simple message
even when people are so far away and
feel so powerless to help
the light of human kindness
shines on
ender brady sky news at winchester
cathedral